[Music]
this week nfl players reported to
training camp the kansas city chiefs are
set to defend their super bowl
championship but they will be without
their starting lineman
laurent duvernay tardif who announced he
is sitting out this season
he's just the second medical school
graduate to compete in the nfl
and spent nine weeks in the off season
helping out in his hometown of montreal
during the height of the covet 19
outbreak
it was kind of a crazy off season you
know you win the super bowl
and then everything is shut down it's a
pandemic it was the culmination of a
dream
for kansas city chief's offensive
lineman laurent duvernay tardif
winning the super bowl back in february
it was an amazing moment we won in miami
48 hours later we had the parade in
kansas city where like a million people
showed up and it was just amazing
to be able to do that with your friends
your family the rest of the celebration
like vacation with his longtime
girlfriend was cut short
news of the coronavirus spread sent them
back to quebec canada
their off-season home once you were back
how much thought did it take
for you in deciding that you wanted to
help out in some way
well at the beginning i feel like for
everybody it was like how do we manage
it personally everything is canceled and
you're kind of frustrated about the
situation
but at some point you realize i'm
privileged you know i still have a job
you know i'm well my family is safe
so then you start thinking all right how
can i contribute how
how can i help laurent was in a unique
position to help
having already graduated from medical
school
drafted by the chiefs in 2014 he'd
gotten cooperation from the team
and montreal's prestigious mcgill
medical school to follow a four-year
curriculum where he'd do four months of
study
while playing nfl football when i walk
on that stage in 2018 and got that md
[Music]
it was one of the best moments of my
life and then once i
lived at that lombardi trophy i feel
like i was able to
combine my true passion at the highest
level laurent traces his sense of
curiosity and adventure back to his
childhood
on extended sailing trips with his
family he fell in love with football as
a teenager
but in academics medicine was not his
first love
i was more focused on engineering but i
realize quickly you gotta be good with
your computer and i'm not really good
with technology
[Laughter]
so i kind of felt like medicine was the
perfect balance between
human attraction and science while
laurent
was able to balance football and
medicine while getting his md
playing in the nfl kept him from doing
his residency
without it he couldn't work as a doctor
in a hospital
even in a pandemic but he did get a
chance to use his training
working in a long-term care facility did
you hesitate at all
no if you think there was a crisis in
the general population
i mean in inside those long-term care
facilities it was 10 times worse so they
needed people to go there and help
and it's only when when i got the call
saying you're starting tomorrow
that i actually start asking myself
question like
am i allowed to do that with my nfl
contract uh how is it gonna play out
with my girlfriend
with my parents how we're going to
manage it this apartment was
part of managing it as far as keeping
his family safe
laurent used it as a transitional zone
after every shift to shower and wash his
clothes before going back home
as for the nfl risk he turned to chief's
head coach andy reed
whose mother by coincidence was also a
mcgill med school graduate
he said like do what you got to do like
you've worked all those years for a
reason
and right now that's the the best thing
you can do is to go back and help and
i remember him saying like this is this
is actually bigger than football
it's about how can you help and save
life or at least be part of a team who
would do so so for nine weeks laurent
followed his coach's advice
working as what he called a nurse slash
doctor slash orderly
what was the hardest thing for you
working in this facility when i first
started
at the beginning i was really focused on
like
all right give me a task and i'm going
to do it to the best of my ability you
know whether it's
passing medication uh changing diapers
feeding people
i quickly realized there's a difference
between treating
and caring for for a patient it's about
making them comfortable and also making
sure that they preserve
their dignity and for me working in in
this environment
i feel like my mindset really changed
and that is when he became vulnerable
that's when you start
interacting with human being instead of
sick patients
and when you do that that's really
taking a toll on you emotionally because
you're taking your phone you're
facetiming you know a patient's family
and you see
the whole family you know crying in
front of their computer because it's the
first
time that they actually seen their
father you know for the past
eight weeks it wasn't all tears
laurent was able to bring some joy using
his nfl status and contacts
i reached out to two of my friends that
actually played for the montreal
canadien and i was like guys
can you send me two jerseys and can we
face time after my shift at three
o'clock
and you're gonna make two patients so
happy and that's what we did and it was
an amazing experience
for the patient but also just for the
personnel in general like those guys
were amazing and they took the time to
like
talk to the nurse and talk to the people
and i think that that was kind of my job
going in there
once again combining his two passions
football
and medicine those nine weeks have been
so
rich uh to a certain extent and and so
emotionally challenging and i feel like
people that i've been working in those
facilities for the past 30 years
we owe them a lot and right now more
than ever some doctors some nurses are
living in like
trailer park because they don't want to
infect their family or bring it back
home to their kids
and to see that people are coming every
day
with a smile on their face trying to
bring joy
and do good it's really touching
you haven't gone through your residency
yet but it seems like this
is already making you a better doctor
yeah for sure
it's been quite an experience to be
honest it was not an easy one but i
think i learned a lot
learning how to work with the the team
around you there's no more
hierarchy it's everybody working
together
in order to better care for the patient
last week laura announced he would sit
out the 2020 nfl season
in a statement he wrote i cannot allow
myself to potentially transmit the virus
in our communities
simply to play the sport that i love if
i am to take risks
i will do it caring for patients
when we spoke in june he had been
planning to return
but that eventual final choice between
football and medicine
was something already looming how much
longer do you play football and when do
you focus
on medicine instead honestly i don't
know i don't have that answer
i always told myself you know after a
super bowl maybe i'm going to call it a
day but
uh you can't now i can't i just love
football i still want to be on that
field i still want to
you know go and win it again and it's my
passion you know and i feel like once
you
once you stop playing football there's
no going back i can be a doctor for the
next 30 years but
if i can be a football player for the
next two three four years i think i'm
gonna be a
happy man you know after talking with
him it didn't surprise me last week to
hear that decision it was really obvious
that this had a huge impact on him and i
do believe he wants to play football
again
right now he's trying to consider what
he's going to do perhaps he could work
in medicine this off season he has a
great foundation with kids that he can
work with too
um but it's just important to remember
this was his decision we talked about
the nba players
his personal decision and we hope to
hear from him again to see exactly what
he will be doing
you can tell how much he's thought about
all this yeah so much i don't know how
you would go through that
and not be changed even as a doctor but
what a great way to start this medical
career
that he has and also the way he talks
about the other doctors and nurses who
are showing up at these places the joy
they have in knowing that they're
helping right and taking
care of these especially elderly
patients in these long-term care
facilities who that's what matters their
dignity at the end of the day i'm trying
to talk to relatives